[Musique]
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
enfin les enfants beaux soient pas trop
où nous mais qu'est ce que tu racontes
nounours je ne comprends rien je parle
comme notre petite amie phoque pas trop
hulu ou le look oui qu'est ce que tu dis
je dis que je descend vite raconté une
histoire de loup nous à mes petits amis
ont des sols et hop hop hop hop hop
on se
régale à te raconter une histoire une
histoire du loup et non oui une nouvelle
aventure de loulou le petit
[Musique]
instant je vous prie là je me pose
ecoutez-moi attentivement déco de noces
le marin pêcheur breton avait beaucoup
d'amis dont la petite île ce qui est
étonnant oui et tous ses amis étaient
pêcheurs marins et bretons évidemment
mais juste en face de chez lui habitait
dans une vieille maison noire le pêcheur
le plus vilain et qui avaient le plus
méchant caractère de tout le pays
[Applaudissements]
un jour en revenant de la pêche le
vilain bonhomme posa devant sa porte
un panier plein de sardines fraîches et
rentra chez lui
loulou appuyé à la fenêtre de sa maison
regardez comme tous les phoques loulou
était gourmand et ses moustaches
commencèrent à relever et sa petite lan
bronze aussi
nous ces sardines ont l'air bonnes
personne ne me voit
loulou sauter en bas de la fenêtre mais
imaginez ça me
régale il faisait sauter les poissons
sur le bout de son nez et les havanais à
toute vitesse
il ne restait plus qu'une seule sardines
dans le panier
quand la porte de l'homme aux méchants
caractère s'ouvrir
londres infante qui t'a permis de manger
mais sert nine fowler et un bâton à la
main il couru derrière le loup qui se
sauva à tout nageoires chez lui
laisser loulou laisser mon froc s'écria
le petit âne
car ne ment je te préviens citron fuck
me fait encore quelques farces je
rattrape et je le vend au marché et la
bombe et chant caractère rentra chez lui
en claquant la porte mécha le petit yann
était fort triste et il raconte à la
mésaventure de loups à son papa le marin
pêcheur breton gronda le jeune phoque
qui promit hop le rendant ses moustaches
donne plus recommencer
et voilà les enfants l'histoire est
terminée elle vous a plu
et bien je vous donne le libre merci une
annonce je vais le mettre dans la
bibliothèque
à présent
les enfants elle s'en plaint
[Musique]
vanina noces bonne nuit mes chers petits
fait pour eux
[Musique]
nos salaires bien gai oui patron je suis
content l'aviez balle vous ne trouvez
pas oui nounours on livre à en route
bonne nuit des enfants faites de beaux
rêves
l'album le vol
[Musique]
et
m
[Musique]
oh
[Applaudissements]
hamon
e
[Musique]